and by the way those of you that are
multi level some of you are in such it
you got your head stuck so far up your
multilevel that you didn't hear a thing
i said all you heard was negative
because you're in a freakin cult
mentality and so if you're one of those
is in a freaking cult mentality jump in
the creek i could care less what you
think okay but if you're a legitimate
multi-level operator I didn't just say
multi-level are all bad if you're a
legitimate operator you don't have to
hype some housewife in and drive a wedge
between her and her husband for you to
win at your business that's just
straight up evil and wrong crap and
those of us that aren't in your little
deal are sick of you when you come at us
with your little cult mentality so jump
in the creek if you don't like it if
you're in one and it's legitimate you're
really doing some good stuff I'm fine
with that I got no issue I got several
friends that are doing some really cool
stuff the Beachbody team is doing some
really cool stuff I'll give them an
endorsement right now but there's some
freaks in that thing too I mean there's
some freaks and every one of these
things and so you know you jump in there
and be a real person and legitimize the
business gameplan and legitimize the
product line by doing something with it
and prove that it's a good operation and
some of these things are good operations
but you people get so whacked about it
that none of us can talk to you and
honestly the rest of us are sick of you
this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you